we're about to get so freaking fancy
right now
in front of me is the tom brown samsung
galaxy
z fold 2 special edition and there's so
many goodies in here i cannot wait to
show it to you
so i'm not going to wait i'm just going
to open it up first let's take a look at
the box
this is substantial like this is hefty
we're greeted with this beautiful
little design like the box feels nice
it smells nice smell that high fashion
that smells like a person
oh god it smells so fancy in there now
this is a premium unboxing experience if
i've ever had one like look at this this
looks like something like you would get
like a fancy hat
or like some fancy shoes we're getting a
lot of fancy things we're getting a
z-fold too we're getting galaxy buds
we're getting a
watch like there's so much inside of
here
[Music]
we've got a little note this is tom
wrote this for sure
tom was he hand wrote this and then
someone transcribed it
a shift in perspective a world opened
the perfection of the fold this is a
beautifully designed package
you have your z fold we have our buds
live and the watch three
there's an extra little what is this
there's a drawer this is like a jewelry
box there's a drawer
that has some extra accessories we have
extra watch bands
you wow premium
this is this is premium
content right here i've actually never
put a case on the z-fold so this is
going to be the first time testing out
putting a case on it
feels very nice where do i even start
what should i open first i don't even
know i think i need to take a picture of
this because it looks really nice all
right let's take these out of the main
box we've got our watch three
got our buds live and
the z fold two 5g this has been one of
my favorite phones like it's
really just such an awesome device i've
had so much fun with it i can't wait to
see this one
oh wow wow wow
look at this look at this
would you take a look at this
[Music]
oh man this is awesome
wow so it has this really
nice kind of a matte finish glass on it
which i really really like and it's got
kind of a
silverish i would say it's kind of like
a dark graphite kind of hinge
and this has kind of some raised little
you hear that i actually kind of like
back so i can
grip on to it that's nice let's power it
on
it's got a custom it just had a custom
little intro
i love the z fold it's really freaking
cool
all right while this is checking for
updates you know what we've got to do
we've got two more things to open up
hold your horses there's more in here
look
they've even got these little custom
bags for all of the accessories
[Music]
shut up they have these cute little cord
wraps
with a little button on it i'm losing my
freaking mind the usb
cable even has the little logo on it as
well
if you're a tom brown fan you are on
cloud
freaking nine right now because this
is awesome do you think the power cable
is gonna have a little accessory
oh my goodness it's also
like this is how you do a premium
integration i mean this is
wow time for the buzz live
oh tom brown second edition so they even
have custom
wallpaper they have custom icons let's
open this up and oh look at that
it's so cool they have all the custom
icons they've got some wallpaper
custom experience here's the buds live
they also have a custom case for this as
well
oh these little bags and look at this
another usbc cable with the cute
little button wraps these are just
i have i said that i like these little
bags yet
okay here's the buds live let's open it
up and see
oh my gosh this is look at this these
everything is so detailed like the
attention to detail on this
is just unbelievable
how cool is that
[Music]
oh hey just wondering do you like tom
brown
yeah we've got our tom brown buds lives
we've got our tom brown z-fold two
now we need to open up our tom brown
watch three i'm actually really excited
about this because during the
announcement i was like huh
that watch three has got some pretty
cool features and now we have a nice tom
brown one
to match all of our other accessories oh
my gosh this looks really good
this is very nice
like there is no doubt about it the
quality
of all of this stuff is
incredibly premium there's no other word
for it like is what is better than
premium
i'm still thinking so this watch band
actually matches the background that is
on the z-fold 2. you also have two other
watch band options in case you want to
switch it up can you imagine just going
out on the town with your
tom brown phone watch your buzz live
and wearing a tom brown outfit
okay check this out check this out look
at this look at this see here's the
background that i was talking about z
fold two backgrounds
watch band matches let's pair this watch
up
oh oh it's asking me if i want to add it
yes add aloud do whatever you want
hello yeah we're ready
this is my first time testing out a
galaxy watch and so far
i'm really enjoying the experience i
mean
fashion week this is gonna be my fashion
life now
guys i've never tried the galaxy watch
before
this is my first time i like that you
can turn the dial i can find all of my
apps
wow this is a pretty good experience
this is cool
let's see what else can we enter you
guys have already given us so many
incredible things
there we go charging cable look this is
even nice too
i love that they have a very consistent
theme oh my gosh
just look at that freaking fancy
i can feel even fancier because i even
have the case to put on now
it's going in oh this gives you two
options for cases so you can have this
little fold-over case like this
i thought these both went together but
no this is two separate cases
so you have this you can open up to see
your front you've also got this option
look that match is so great i think i
might like
this case the best because if i'm gonna
protect this thing
she's like are you trying to see my
notifications no
this was so awesome to check out the tom
brown edition of the samsung galaxy z
fold a huge thank you to samsung for
letting me check this out unfortunately
i do have to send this back to them but
this was
really awesome to be able to show you
guys how cool of an unboxing
experience this is it was such a great
presentation and honestly there is
nothing that i love more than a really
cool unboxing experience
and this by far is definitely up there
in some of my top
favorite unboxing experiences so thank
you guys so much for watching if you
guys want to subscribe
be sure to do so because i will have
tons more videos coming out it is
the tech season after all i'll see you
[Music]
later
you